why don't you tell us a little bit about
algorithms IO before we get this up and
running my name is Andy Bartley as
professor - I mentioned one of the
cofounders of algorithms IO we provide
predictive analytics for the Internet of
Things so what I'm going to talk about
okay great great so I'm gonna try and
keep my my comments brief and as jargon
free as possible for those that have
looked at big data there's a lot of sort
of marketing suite that goes around the
space so I'll try and tell you
practically what we do in a couple of
slides I will talk a little bit about
some of the things that are happening in
the market with cloud adoption and I've
tailored some of that some of those
comments specifically to the Asian
market by the focus of today's
conversation that's a little bit more of
an academic talk about what's going on
in cloud computing and then I have a
couple of anecdotal examples based on
our experience doing business now with
some larger organizations in Asia on
some of the ways that our approach to
delivering these analytics as cloud
services versus locally installed
software products has innovated some of
the traditional sales and business
cycles that that we see over in Asia so
and again I'm going to keep this
high-level brief I think what we're
looking forward to today is your
questions to dig into topics that are of
interest to use so I move quickly
through keep questions and really look
forward to discussing those with you
afterwards
so what we do at algorithms i/o as I
mentioned is is we help make sense of
the massive amounts of streaming data
that's coming off of Internet of Things
devices for those that are familiar with
the term Internet of Things it's sort of
a fancy way of saying any device that's
connected to the Internet these are
things like monitors that sit on patient
bed sides in hospitals collecting
temperature and respiration these are
things like sensors that sit on
manufacturing equipment monitoring
temperature and vibration and they're
also things like your smartphone which
collects accelerometer gyroscope data
all of this data is
is streamed up into the cloud into our
service and what we do is we build data
models that turn these raw streams of
data and you can see above me you know
events per second and some raw streaming
accelerometer data we turn that data
that raw data into discrete actions or
events and we and we let different
industries customize those models
specific to the industry so we have
predictive models for manufacturing to
determine when equipments going out of
calibration we have them for healthcare
to determine when hospital conditions or
leading to a higher risk of sepsis we
have those for wearables devices so that
by using a consumer wearable like a
Fitbit instead of just understanding how
far you've run the device can
intelligently find out what you're doing
at any given time based on the data
being streamed off so what we do is we
make sense of sensor data as I mentioned
we make it very easy to build
classification models based on machine
learning algorithms that turn that raw
stream of data into specific activities
or events and give you insights into
what's going on the classification step
for streaming data is really important
because until you understand what the
data is telling you you can't do things
like drive business decisions
you can't automate factories you can't
make recommendations and actually give
actionable insight based on that data
first thing you need to do is classify
it once you've classified it folks can
understand how to actually take that
inside their companies and act on it so
I mentioned at the end I'll go back in
and run a quick demo just to show you
some classification running with my
mobile phone if we have a little work I
think I've got it okay yeah yeah be
easier so as I mentioned what we do
that's a little different than other
players in the market today is that we
provide all these predictive analytics
as a cloud service so essentially we
combine the infrastructure of AWS along
with the data scientists along with the
application developer we wrap that all
up into one package so a company can get
started with the full machine learning
predictive analytics solution with the
very low monthly fee we actually have a
free developer tier where folks can come
in can connect a device directly to our
platform can start streaming data in and
getting results back within an hour the
data coming out of our
platform is fed back into different
reports applications and visualizations
so folks can take that information
either build great consumer apps based
on hardware devices or use those for
Intel reports the cloud platform I'll
show you here just really briefly this
is the high-level view of the
architecture that we've developed one of
the things that we do that's a little
different is that we abstract algorithms
into reusable building blocks and you
can see that in our tier here it's a
little different approach to deploying
algorithms inside the enterprise
traditionally machine learning is deeply
embedded into core code of software
applications we abstract those out into
these reusable blocks and we provide
some glue code that lets you combine
algorithms written in different
programming languages together very
quickly so say if you have a thousand
customers and you want to break those
customers down into individual smaller
units with the clustering algorithm you
can do that and then based on those
units you can apply a recommendation
algorithm written in a different
language very quickly so you can build
these algorithm workflows on our cloud
platform I mentioned a couple of use
cases for our service today we're
working with a few consumer wearables
companies this is the Kiwi wearables
device company out of Canada and the
node sensor company out of the Midwest
we're also working with some folks and
energy and manufacturing as I said
before building predictive models to
help to understand energy consumption
and manufacturing facilities and when
machines are going out of Tolerance also
in the healthcare space doing some
predictive modeling to determine when
certain conditions in the hospital lead
to higher risk for certain types of
infections that impact the hospital
system quite a bit so you know why are
we why are we providing analytics in the
cloud right why aren't we going more the
traditional enterprise model that
analytics have have been delivered and
historically so these are some numbers
about the the cloud analytics market
today it's about a three billion dollar
market growing at a very healthy rate of
about twenty six twenty six percent a
year you can see up on the up on the I
think the bottom right or left I'm not
sure what it is from your angle but some
of the traditional players in the space
you see are si PS your Oracle's your IBM
s in there about a third of the cloud
analytics market though is this other
space which is emerging companies like
ourselves that are out there providing
these analytical
tools in a more lightweight easy-to-use
format and we're providing those tools
along with the infrastructure that you
need in order to store the data so you
don't have to get your database from an
Oracle and then your analytics from a
downloadable si P we provide all of that
with you to you in one in one complete
package for our talk today an
interesting thing to note is that behind
the United States which is the world's
largest economy for analytics
asia-pacific is a second so asia-pacific
is really driving a lot of demand around
the migration to cloud and the the
demand for analytics delivered as cloud
solutions and a lot of that is driven by
Internet of Things and connected devices
so this is some work done by Cisco
taking a look at cloud adoption in the
u.s. versus cloud adoption in Asia and
this compares cloud adoption for
consumer cloud use as well as cloud
adoption for business use and you can
see the business use of cloud public
cloud is taxed pretty closely between
the US and Asia both both regions have a
lot of hesitations with moving to the
cloud if folks have studied that space
there's a lot of concerns about security
how do I move from on-premise to the
cloud what happens about performance and
so the business side is is run
relatively parallel to each other in
terms of growth the interesting thing is
that the consumer cloud usage in
asia-pacific driven largely by wearable
devices and a proliferation of mobile
devices is driving an incredible
opportunity for new cloud providers
inside the asia-pacific region
an interesting thing alongside of that
is sort of the economics of the cloud so
you know if anybody studied AWS they've
dropped their price 19 times in the past
five years so we see consistent
decreases in the pricing for cloud
compute but increased demand so how are
these cloud providers maintaining higher
margin growing the business they're
adding on value add features and value
add features or things like making
Hadoop very easy use adding video
transcoding as a service on top of cloud
platforms and these value-added features
typically run about 20% more a higher
margin over standard compute so a couple
things in Asia we've got higher demand
for cloud
and we have this this move to a more
modular platform type infrastructure in
order to add value-added services so
what we're seeing right now in Asia as a
result of this demand for a new consumer
cloud infrastructure is that the several
large players and we've talked to you
about a half a dozen large enterprise
players in in Asia
these are companies that are not in the
cloud market today but they're all
planning public cloud releases so what
we expect to see in Asia over the next
12 to 18 months is this rush to the
cloud and we expect to see a variety of
new cloud offerings from very
traditional enterprise organizations
inside the agent market and these
companies have had the benefit of
studying what's happened with Amazon
what I mentioned before that Amazon's
had to reduce their prices 19 times in
the past five years and had to add on
value-added services in order to
increase margin so what'll be
interesting to watch is is the these
Asian companies introduced their own
cloud solutions they're also looking for
platforms of service solutions analytics
layers additional value-added features
they could put on top of those clouds to
help drive up and protect margin in
those markets so what that means is you
know have cloud need pass right sort of
on the on the you know side of the road
with the sign up looking for that
provider so companies like ours that are
providing a full analytic suite the
infrastructure along with the algorithms
along with the visualizations fit very
nicely into this evolving cloud economy
over in Asia and it was a result of that
we've been in a fortunate position of
speaking with a number of those
companies and we're getting moving
forward with several which we're looking
forward to announced at the later latter
half of this year it's also how I came
to meet professor - went through some of
those conversations okay just wrapping
up so what does this mean in terms of
disruption I'll bring up three points
that we've seen again these are
anecdotal based on our experience first
is faster more customized pilots this is
very important in getting product out
into the users hands over in Asia and
what these pilots do today that's
different so if one of these larger
companies wants to use analytics is that
with the cloud solution you can highly
customized a pilot in a matter of days
that uses actual customer data and this
is very different from traditional pilot
programs
trying out new technologies which
typically take weeks or months what that
does is it really shortens your sales
adoption cycles so you can see up top
sort of the traditional sales cycle and
and this is sort of a characterization
based on again our conversations with a
variety of companies in Korea and Japan
China it takes very very long to bring a
us-based technology into these markets
typically 12 to 24 months is our
experience and you know I'd be curious
to hear folks in the room have a
different experience with that but many
meetings internal debate decisions
typically many folks involved in this in
the discussion on whether to move
forward a small internal pilot further
discussion than an external pilot with
customer information and more discussion
and finally if things work out you
actually get to bring a product to
market what we've been able to do by
providing this as a cloud is go directly
to proof of concept trials with direct
customer data so really by past six to
twelve months of internal lead time to
bring new products to market and as
these companies are looking at this
they're realizing that they can break
out of their traditional application
development cycles of two one to two
years and actually bring your
applications to market in several months
which is something that's very new for
those economies final thing I'll mention
is hope is this move to cloud his
forcing companies to rethink how they
calculate lifetime value especially
companies that have provided analytics
historically and this is true in Asia
and this is true here in the United
States so traditionally a large amount
of an enterprise software contract comes
from services service fees so those are
people in the enterprise that are that
are working with these companies to help
upkeep and maintain when you move that
to the cloud you abstract away a lot of
the complexities with managing these
applications inside the enterprise and
so companies that are using analytics as
a service or realizing that the lifetime
value how you extract value out of your
customers going forward is really about
the value add features as I mentioned
before that you build into your offering
versus those heavy service contracts and
that changes the dynamics and that
changes the calculations around business
model and a customer lifetime value for
a lot of these a lot of these new
companies in analytics
so we talked about a little bit about
what we do at algorithms through some
stuff at you about the Asia market
what's happening in Asia and cloud
adoption there and also talked about
some of the disruption we're seeing as a
result of these new algorithms and
analytics as a service business model so
try to keep it with a couple of topics
pertinent to today I'll leave it there
and then we can fire off questions here
a little bit I think that's great Andy
while I'm setting up for the next
presentation I want to point out so we
haven't had a chance to talk much about
big data and big data analytics and
cloud computing so far in the series but
with these analytics companies are able
to measure what people are actually
doing online with their products or with
advertising and so forth it's giving
companies for instance advertisers
amazing information about you know
empirical information about what people
are actually doing not only as they're
watching that web site but every click
that they will have later during the day
so it's a huge range of new data
especially with all the social media
websites out there and it's already
really changing the kind of advertising
and marketing industries we have a
presentation on that that point coming
up in a couple of weeks what's
interesting though is that right now
there's a shortage of these people
called data scientists who can deliver
custom-made analytics to solve specific
problems each specific problem really
needs to be formulated in a very
rigorous way it's not just the knowledge
of computer science that's important and
so a certain amount of customization is
required for each kind of these
analytics that's being developed what
algorithms IO is doing is modularizing
that process and if you remember my talk
last week a little bit about how the
automobile wasn't really disruptive
until the Model T Ford came along this
may be a similar kind of development in
how analytics are developed because by
modular rising
you can reuse elements of code a lot
better and it becomes a much more
efficient process there is going to be
this continuing need for customization
though and with regard to the whole kind
of customization area and how analytics
that are solving specific problems work
we have another presentation today and
did yob is the CEO of crowd analytics
which is using another kind of very
popular radically new technique called
crowdsourcing and he's got a community
of data scientists that a customer would
pose a problem to and then this
community can come up with a good
solution
kind of like the Linux open to the open
source development community has got
several groups so that will do this kind
of development so DIF yob would you give
us some remarks here shut Williams up do
you want to try to do this or Charlotte
okay let's do that
all right thanks Richard hello everyone
so just to give you a quick summary of
what I will be covering today
Andy's already talked to us about what's
driving big data growth a lot of you
guys have heard of big data there is a
lot of confusion as well out there it's
an evolving field I'm not gonna add my
own perception to that to add to the
noise I'm going to focus on what we are
hearing from our customers and primarily
try to address the challenges that
companies across industries are
currently facing in adopting big data
you've of course you know Hadoop is
there the technology is there and lots
of new technologies is driving big data
but there are a lot of challenges that
companies are facing and I'll try to
focus on that and how we are trying to
address those challenges
and our experience has been across
industries so that kind of gives you a
good picture of what's going on in
various areas in which which industries
are actually doing better than others
but before I get into that just a quick
summary of what we are about
crowd analytics because it is a new
concept and I just want to quickly
explain that you guys we now have a
community of data scientists as Richard
mentioned this is a scarce resource we
have people across 50 countries more
than 3000 of them are now aggregated on
our platform and are available for us to
solve any data analytics problems now
there are problems that are you know as
far as the data is concerned it's clear
what you want the problem definition is
right and known but there are many
problems out there right now because
this area is evolving it's very
difficult to know firstly how to even
define the problem how to identify which
data sources to utilize if it is the
advertising you are talking about if you
want to predict a customer's behavior
which data sources are important it's
it's it's not an easy question to answer
not only that a data scientist has one
perspective right he might be a great
guy but he still has biases we eliminate
those biases by getting the community to
compete against each other so any
project held on our platform is is held
as a competition and you will find
hundreds of data scientists competing
independently coming up with solutions
and those the best of those solutions
are then delivered to the customer so
that's that's our process we primarily
look at public data because it's its
most of the data by the way the big data
that you you look at most of it is
publicly available and the rest of the
transactional data has always been there
so we try to focus on that that is
climate data there is a data on parking
lots there's data on accidents crimes
real estate social media all of this
data
can give you immense amount of knowledge
about you know companies and actionable
insights so that's that's the process we
use just a quick thing on how it works
so we any customer comes to us there is
a discovery phase we engage with the
customer understand his problem as I
said the biggest challenge is
translating a business challenge into a
modeling challenge that the two guys
don't even understand their language
each of those languages so for example a
data scientist is thinking in terms of
modeling and a marketing guy and I have
seen this across industries now
marketing guy is not able to communicate
his thoughts in a manner that a data
scientist understands this communication
gap is what we fill through our solution
managers once the problem is translated
from a business one into a modeling one
this is then posed to the community they
come back with models which we then
package again as actionable insights for
these companies so a marketing guy is
more interested in prediction of what a
customer wants to buy or he wants to
know what is the ROI of his marketing
mix what is the most optimum mix that he
should be utilizing and the data
scientist is thinking in terms of what
data sets to utilize how to clean up the
data how to merge different data sets we
fill that gap okay now this is a quick
snapshot of the kind of people we have
so yes resources are scarce and scarce
across u.s. and India or any other part
of the world this is common why is it
scarce and Andy will probably agree with
me many of these mathematicians don't
really want to be associated with one
type of problem okay this is this is
their they they would rather remain
horizontal they are thinking numbers to
them predicting the condition of a heart
is the same as predicting the quality of
wine they don't care and they would
rather remain independent so the best
guys are independent consultants and
we've just aggregated all of them just a
quick thing on how algorithms get opting
my stride on our platform within a very
short period so Andy talked about speed
to market think of it as parallel
processing of the experimentation
process when you are doing a new big
data analytics there is a bunch of trial
and error phase that you go through this
happens in all industries all
organizations when you are running a
pilot you will you know the first step
you build a model you try it out you
tune it you test it on real data you go
back and do it all over again
if you're doing this with one data
scientist it takes a while and that's
one of the reasons the cycle times as
big as 12 months to 24 months we are
parallel processing this entire process
okay off of testing trying and tuning so
every time a model is developed by any
of the data scientists we update a
leaderboard with their you know in case
of predictive analytics we would have a
prediction error which clearly says how
good or bad their algorithm is okay the
moment that score is on the leaderboard
the next guy comes and tries to beat it
okay this process is repeated the
benchmark keeps moving because it's it's
a live public place where you're you're
on display and just like many of you you
want to do better than your peers okay
so the the moment you know let's say a
guy in the US was on top of the
leaderboard by the time he wakes up in
the morning some guy in India or China
has already beaten him and then he wants
to go back and do that again
this process is work exactly so that is
what is as shown by this curve which
which shows how quickly within four
weeks we reach a point where no further
improvement is possible and in the in
the model and this is the algorithm that
gets developed and and delivered to the
customer okay why is all of this
required
algorithms exist okay there are 50 or 60
types of different algorithms across
machine learning and statistics there's
nothing new about that that's existed
for a while and it's been derived from
artificial intelligence
the field of artificial intelligence and
there's just enough algorithms out there
what you feed into the algorithm is just
not a science it's an art okay and and
that is what causes all of these
variations and it's amazing how you see
these variations right and when you test
it out on the platform so just quickly
so that was a quick intro on how we do
it but I just want you guys to see where
big data is as far as we are seeing
right from discussions with companies
are doing fraud analytics paitent
analytics customer analytics we've done
climate analytics for prediction of
flood so we have a broad you know
experience we've now executed about 40
competitions this is where the industry
is okay's people like cloud era have
ensured that you you know the only thing
cloud era is doing is scaring the hell
out of you and telling you I hope that's
okay those guys are not there no problem
okay so what they're doing is they're
telling you look you need to keep all of
your data okay it could be data created
by your video or audio or anything at
all that you've been throwing so far or
putting into your magnetic tapes they
need to be on your Hadoop server why are
they doing it because unless you reach a
scale of one terabyte or more cloud era
is not needed so what are they saying
right this is basically where it is okay
I'm not exaggerating at all so stop you
know when you're vacuuming your place
stop vacuuming it keep all the dirt with
you you never know there could be a gold
particle there somewhere that you are
throwing along with the dirt this is
what cloud era is telling people okay
now post that and this is where everyone
is so so the the fraud analytics guy
there are banks they will say look
before I was I didn't have all the
technology and bandwidth so all I did
was randomly do some sort of fraud
transaction analysis today analyze each
and every transaction I have the the
the ability to do so so let me analyze
each transaction that's where people are
heading everyone is stuck at first
deploying their Hadoop itself okay
unfortunately that's where the world is
so what do you do that's one problem the
second problem is scarcity of resources
I've already talked to you about that
you can't find people it's impossible
most of the best guys are risk modelers
60% of them are in financial services
companies that's where this most
sophisticated guys have been that's
where they get the biggest salaries and
everyone else who gets nothing
so that's that's another problem
business execs and data scientists don't
understand each other okay this is just
you can't talk literally it's it's it's
to that level so you know I went to this
data-driven marketing event the first
one by the way in New York and everyone
has heard of predictive analytics and
everyone is there you know saying that
you know something's happening let me
also be part of it but nobody has a clue
as to how to utilize it okay so these
were our initial conversations where we
went and thought that let me go and talk
to them and understand what they want I
got nothing literally they just did not
know what they want okay so what did we
do we went somewhat in the same route as
Andy but in our own way where we are now
pre building certain solutions using the
community okay so we would rather give
you business solutions then try to
explain to you how all of this happens
okay and and nobody gets it and usually
you want your selling to business users
data scientists don't even exist as I
said in in most of these organizations
so some of the so for example right just
a quick example and there are many that
we've gone through and and this is
definitely resonating which is think of
it this as a simple and by the way even
this is not happening yet right so you
have social media monitoring you have
people filtering information so that you
can respond to some some of your
customers
there are sites that provide what your
competitor might be doing which is of
value but nobody is trying to identify
correlations in all of the various data
streams if you tweeted on Tuesday
morning what is the probability or you
know off of it getting retweeted say 10
times or 20 times nobody is telling this
okay it's why and that's the the
question that question is more important
and that is because people are taking
the tools approach and a tool can take
you only that far because there are
plenty of correlations at what we are
doing is on in real time on our server
we have 20 digital streams constantly
being streamed we look at a slice of
time and we tell you what impact your
tweet is having on your Google trend or
what impact your YouTube video like is
having on your you know retweets this is
something that's impossible because when
a community looks at millions of
correlations there is a need for some
human intervention at this point to
identify which is the signal and which
is noise and there is always I mean a
model will give you a bunch of
correlations correlations is easy what
is the junk in there actually does
require a guy with a magnifying glass
and that's what we are trying to do ok
so this is a this is one of the kind of
business solutions that is resonating
with clients similarly we are doing
climate analytics we've done paitent
analytics that one is a very interesting
one where we analyze 22,000 h1 and 1
patents around h1n1 virus as you know
these viruses keep mutating and hence
the vaccine needs to keep updating so
it's a huge process and and it's a very
costly process for these guys what we
did is we looked at these 22,000
molecules and we identified the top 22
or 30 that should become the starting
point for building the vaccine we saved
close to four or five months of time in
in doing so because look the fundamental
form pharmaceutical research days are
over okay there are many patented
molecules
and usually a new vaccine is a
amalgamation of those molecules so smart
grid analytics just helping you look at
energy data and for example you have
these smart meters now in and it's going
to come in almost every house and the
energy uses is getting recorded you know
the signature of each device in your
house so you know when the fridge you
know got turned on or when the light
bulb turned on there is a certain wave
pattern that gets created we looked at
this algorithm and we try to split those
signals so that we can provide itemized
almost like a credit card statement can
we provide an itemized energy usage bill
to you where an air-conditioner you know
exactly which device is is consuming
more energy so that you can improve on
it or maybe an air conditioning company
can come back and tell you look take try
this out for free your consumption will
go down so that that's again and CRM
analytics so we've looked at online
customer behavior and so recommendation
engines are good when you already
basically someone has already bought a
product imagine you have a new product
and you have a new customer I can tell
you what is the likelihood of this new
customer liking this new product so
we've done that for an online so we've
done this now across industries and
we've worked in US and India so I don't
have experience in Asia so I'm not going
to talk about that but in India the to
the core difference between US and India
is is the availability of data okay the
maturity and the availability of data is
reasonably high in the US data is not
easily available in India and so the
kind of problems we are addressing are
very different as a result in the US for
example in marketing we will focus on
customer retention churn you know
loyalty in India because there are two
reasons one is data is not available and
the second is it's a developing evolving
market
so they are more interested in how do i
acquire new customers and you get me
data on that how do I make my you know
insurance agent more effective so those
are the sort of problems we are dealing
with in India but this is a quick
summary and overview of what we are
doing
hopefully it raises more questions than
answers them so let me ask a question
kind of as follow-up
you mentioned 3,000 data scientists who
are in your community and they're
distributed over 50 countries what is
the scale in terms of number of people
you actually have as employees or
actually working full-time for the
company good question
so the full-time employees are only 10
and and that's that's a very recent
number we've been managing with four
people for a very long time how do we
manage that many of these community
members are also appointed as lead
analysts it's a completely scalable so
the reason we've received investment ok
from someone like axel is because this
is a if it works it's it's going to
disrupt how people do things ok you do
not see the risk of having fixed
resources is gone if you want to try out
and this is an area where trial is
required I mean people are just in the
beginning stages so would you hire 10
very expensive data scientists in your
company and have no guarantee of success
or would you use a community like this
and do you know don't pay if you do if
we don't deliver right so it's a prize
money based like many more possibilities
many more possibility to liver yeah in
fact even if I cannot do better than
what you already have that also proves
something right the fact that 100 people
tried and we could not beat your
solution it means what you have is
pretty good when did you actually start
you've done 40 competitions right yeah
we started about two years back okay and
so you've received venture capital
funding
and your company is still at the stage
of you're about to do the first round of
venture capital right right yeah so in
terms of what you both see is as driving
your respective businesses forward
you've both talked about the challenges
yeah what's really going to push it
forward what do you think is it the
nature of the data the availability of
the data or is it what's gonna push it
forward Andy why don't you go first yeah
so two for us and we touched on this
with going more of the product routes
we're giving you sort of a
pre-configured product it's this
platform with the infrastructure and the
algorithms it's important to pick
specific target verticals it's very
difficult in this space to be a broad
platform for the points that we just
discussed is it that many of these
problems they look different they feel
different they can be different within
different industries different companies
within the same industry are maybe
trying to ask different questions not
everyone is trying to ask the same
question in different industries to get
to get values so for us what's really
important is is to pick a couple of key
verticals where we see some consistency
between what the customers in those
spaces look for so where we're at right
now as a company is speaking with 50
different companies we've had 50 folks
sign up for our machine learning
streaming machine learning platform and
we're doing that validation right now of
the market to see where we can find some
consistent themes between spaces like
healthcare telecom energy manufacturing
some of these larger markets where
there's an opportunity to build a
product that serves multiple customers
but I think your move into looking to
build full solutions those people don't
want to talk about data it's not a fun
topic it's not a sexy topic and it's not
the way that most business people think
about their company revenues not being
generated because of data if you think
about it it's my acquiring customers am
I getting more value out of those
customers so the more that you can
translate the raw data ugly stuff into
into business terminology and business
outcome I think the more effective focus
that I've seen folks in the space being
so whenever there is a
technology and the value of the
technology is clear it's definitely
going to happen you know and it
definitely is going to change how people
companies do business okay there's no
doubt about that the challenges here are
so if you if you look at I forget which
survey this was but the companies with
the most investment in IT are are the
worst in knowing how their customers are
doing why is the question right it's
it's again I go back to that same thing
they do not understand each other it's
not just the IT and it has been with IT
for a very long time you know the first
time and bi was introduced it took ages
for companies to just get their data
together so you had these data
warehouses you had all sorts of data
Mart's built thousands of reports were
being created churned every day nobody
saw any of those reports you know the
machine can give you the report what
unless you do something with it
it's useless yeah okay so I do believe
and this is not just with big data
analytics but has been with BI and
everything else we need to feed the
information in chunks that are
consumable in small chunks to the
business audience and not and basically
hide everything else and once that
starts happening you will see better
adoption because the value is clear I
think everyone knows the value but
there's this big frenzy the CEO says
look everyone is doing big data why
don't you do it as well and there's
investment in IT the marketing doesn't
know what so that that's where the world
is not okay sounds good so for the floor
questions go ahead first one is there
something common between the companies
that you su see who are actually the
first movers in the space those were
trying to leverage it ahead of the other
common body the ones with the highest IQ
investments are probably the one usually
the ones with the lowest runs
understanding of customer what about the
ones who are actually coming to these
new so I think the guys who have their
data sufficiently organized already and
have got a buy-in from their top
management
I think top management buy-in is very
important and where the CMO has a
greater say than the CTO or the CIO okay
companies like that tend to be doing
better
for example Macy's is a great example
they have literally taken it to the
point where every pamphlet was
personalized okay now the CMO needs to
have a lot of power in the organization
for that to happen it's political a lot
of these things are political and how
the organization's are designed if
everyone sees this as a data problem or
an IT problem it is never never gonna
get solved at least that's my view yeah
I think another common theme that we see
is we see a lot of companies in older
more mature industries turning to data
so industries that are experiencing
double-digit growth organically that are
looking for ways to you know turn 2%
growth into three percent growth or four
percent growth so you know manufacturing
healthcare or organizations I guess
healthcare is another good example that
are under duress so you've now been
tasked with squeezing a large amount of
inefficiency out of the system you know
how do you do that there's only so many
things that you can pull the low-hanging
fruit you can pull off the tree before
you have to start to get more analytical
so we see either you know sort of market
pressure driving this either from a
growth perspective or you know to case a
health care regulatory pressure driving
them to think more critically about how
to make changes yeah I think I don't
have anything to add great
ethics you didn't mention that for the
client when you go ahead with some
predefined solutions it's often a lot
easier for him to pick and choose but
don't you think that you know get such a
solution he often does not understand
the intricacies of the model and then so
that might end up killing the product
name of the day so you might try it out
without full understanding and then you
know might not work out that's a good
that's a good question our experience
has shown that the client and especially
clients that do not have data scientists
let's say on the other end okay they're
not even interested in the model
remember one thing these are perishable
goods to a large extent okay algorithms
are dumb the kind of algorithms we are
talking about it that's why it's called
machine learning it's like a chai and
newborn child being fed with a lot of
information and it is that information
that creates the algorithm so they don't
want the model usually what ends up
happening is we get into a longish
association where we keep updating the
model for them and they are more
interested in the outcome right so as
long as they're getting outcomes that
are adding business value they will
continue to come to us and as far as the
model is concerned we keep them away
from them is there a related opportunity
here for maybe educational programs for
people on how to use big data or around
you know the the you mentioned the
solution managers and your staff I would
think that some of what they're doing is
is certainly advocating how to make use
Lord of the discussions that we have
starts off at a very high level so it's
not as if that might be because we are
evolving as a company and that's also
because the client is evolving so we go
in there with with certain ideas and
it's the solution manager that makes
sure that we
a point you know you have to handhold
and bring the client to a place where
he's clear about what we are offering
and that it will add value and and
usually it goes through a pilot phase
just just like Andy mentioned it it's a
trial and error that's where they are
today
Andy I want to follow up with you
briefly your platform is really for
people who would go on and do the final
stages of developing the analytic
solution right mm-hmm
so where's the handoff where's the best
handoff between your platform and what
people do case-by-case customized yeah
so we I mentioned we typically start
with a small pilot internally and we run
that with our internal team with with
those customers so we'll define a vary
and it goes back to you know the
previous comment about education I'm a
lot of what we do up front is help
people think like a data scientist as
much as they're willing to extend
themselves to do that it's not always an
easy task usually we walk in and they
say well we have a problem what's the
algorithm to fix it and and that's not
you know how the process works so time
is spent upfront talking about you know
what's the value of the data what's the
real problem you're trying to solve and
narrowing in and usually the problem is
about a dozen or more problems all
encapsulated into one and in about an
hour or two we're down about an hour to
working with them we can get down to a
specific problem that you can actually
build a model around and then we'll
deploy that internally for us one of the
keys has been to work with customers and
that's at this stage that have internal
resources that we can pass the baton to
so it really saves them time it really
shortens it yeah yeah it's a teach a man
to fish kind of model so we do that
upfront consulting work with them show
them how to use the tool and then we'll
let them run with it we're available to
to you know be there for assistance as
we go forward okay yeah I just wanted to
add to Andy's comment that you know the
area they have chosen is very
interesting the data the
machine-to-machine data is is where the
world is heading and that data is clean
okay clean data is a prerequisite
and because it's generated by machines
there are no gaps and hence the analysis
is much more predictable and accurate so
this is one area where you will see big
data going that's all your hair first
so what challenges do you face when we
try to promote the product in Chinese
and in Asia and then what's prejudice
genius how are your method of acquiring
new customers in the States
are different from doing the same thing
in Asia what do you try to focus on when
you Russ so far the key has been
partners so we haven't entered any of
the markets Japan Korea or China as a
newer market that we just lined up a
partnership to go into without partners
so we're working with larger established
companies in those markets that
understand the sort of the unique
cultural aspects of doing business there
I think you know probably companies
larger companies with more internal
resources can Coen going directly but
for us it's been a partner a partner
role and in with our platform typically
our platform is a white label solution
meaning it's its branded for the
customer that we're working with so we
really work behind the scenes and we
enable that customer to move the
analytics that they're trying to provide
into the cloud so our platform is a tool
that's used by that organization to move
their analytics to the cloud the end
customer in those markets we typically
don't touch so we're working directly to
the business relationship
they help communicate those customer
needs back to us we get the platform set
up accordingly and then the end customer
relationship is still managed by the
company that has a relationships in that
market so China I do not have a lot of
experience have we've sold in India and
in the Indian market the selling happens
at a very high level so in India right
now you have to sell the concept first
and only then do you get an entry they
are more interested in your data than
your analytics okay
so if you have good structured data that
is of more interest because they know
you know that once that exists because
they don't have it so but as far as the
u.s. is concerned lot of our discussions
happen at a much lower level so I am
talking mostly about marketing marketing
you find that there is a lot of leeway
that I'd say a digital marketing manager
has in making decisions on you know
buying products like this so a lot of
the discussions are with marketing folks
as far as marketing solutions go in
India it does not the case I think
that's one clear difference as well as
the market is evolving so the problems
are very different the growth rate is
humongous right right now so if whether
it's retail or whether it's insurance
banking there's growth rates beyond say
seven eight ten percent so they are more
interested in acquisition whereas here
it's more about churn loyalty those sort
of things customer value and a marketing
budget you know providing this as a
service also changes the game in terms
of how easy you make it for folks to do
trials right so now a marketing manager
you're gonna do a trial for several
thousand dollars which means they don't
happen to run budget approval up a lot
yes right so you can get it they can run
another Amex and you're in you get your
foot in the door and submitting your
Trojan horse into the enterprise and
then you can grow that relationship over
time or traditional products you know
don't don't really allow that a couple
of related things you had mentioned that
a one-third of the people providing
analytics are really emerging companies
or as sa P and Oracle or kind of the
existing big players I'm guessing that
on the customer side to the people who
are the most robust customers are
probably multinationals yes and they do
have the data already including some of
their own proprietary data as well as
public data and I'm sure they're
interested in you know this combination
of public cloud and private cloud but
one of the nice things about these two
ideas is that this may open it up to
customers that
don't already have the capacity in house
to develop these kinds of solutions yeah
absolutely and the price points are
ridiculously different from what you
find in traditional models but it is
truly amazing how much Big Data work is
going on in companies like coca-cola or
Walmart some of our labs who just up the
road yeah we've got a team of you know
30 data scientists working there and GE
has like a hundred hundred or two
hundred data scientists now working out
Livermore working specifically on
Internet of Things so you know these
larger companies are making very very
large power companies are critically
worried about how to reduce their mate
not yes yeah so if they can predict when
something's going to fail yeah yeah okay
yep each give us an example of the most
interesting problem that you solve and
I'm also kind of curious about the
privacy policy when it comes to patient
data and hospitals the u.s. has very
tight privacy when it comes to hospitals
very open on the internet right now the
irony there is that may actually impede
cancer research can produce a other
countries which are able to collect the
data yes I used to be a Compliance
Manager for for Streicher medical device
company so I'm very familiar with the
yeah the data data compliance laws so
for anything done on the cloud you can
obfuscate the data to be HIPAA compliant
before it comes out to to work with it
so you do have to take out any
identifiable information from the data
set the the interesting thing anytime
you have a regulation it makes everybody
very nervous most people don't know what
it means so most people just take the
stance that we're not going to work with
it so I think in healthcare today
there's relatively few institutions that
have a technical resource in-house that
is both has the technical savvy and the
understanding of what the regulation
means in order to be comfortable and
understand how to work with the cloud we
probably count them on two hands the
institution's a us to do this so one of
the one of the sort of leaders in the
space is University of California Irvine
gentleman by the name of Charles Boise
there works with a lot of big data
solution
and his bill and he's going to be open
sourcing this next year but really built
a very interesting cloud infrastructure
for ingesting streaming data from the
hospital so he has a real-time view of
everything happening at every hospital
bed inside the University of California
Irvine Health System uses Hadoop uses
some know sequel to pull data out it's
very very interesting stuff so there is
a sea change going on in this space in
terms of thought and understanding of
how to work with this data and also you
know work with that in a more cloud open
model right because he also realizes
that try to manage the infrastructure
the amount of healthcare data available
is is just massive and you start to
combine patient monitoring along with
hospital ambient monitoring and then you
know conditions outside hospitals so
things like how does seasonality or
temperature wintertime summertime impact
inpatient rates the types of infections
as disease going on that's the kind of
analytics that we want to get to in that
space and that takes larger you know
data processing correlates very
different yeah yeah and even you know
regional impact right so what what are
disease states that are more prevalent
here the West Coast versus the East
Coast and how do those change with
seasonality so really getting down it
might go into this so before we get off
the topic of privacy do you find that
your solution to giving things to a
community of data scientists does that
keep companies from coming to you there
are afraid of too many people knowing
their problems yeah so folks like
compliance managers and various
companies they're paranoid about their
data there's no doubt about it there are
various technologies available to
obfuscate the data and to a point where
nobody can even understand what it is
but they're still paranoid about it so
this is this is a problem that exists
and so we are focusing initially what we
do is we focus on public data and value
from public data that's where we are
finding our sweet spot but I have almost
a philosophical response okay to do the
question because I think the real
question there is that if people were
not so paranoid and if if this these
problems were given in an open
innovation environment
would we not find answers quicker right
to cancer or AIDS or any any such thing
and that's a fact
innovations happen better in an open
environment so I think people need to
the the world and this is a statement
that I have made elsewhere protection of
IP was a key competitive advantage over
the last couple of decades but today
with the information availability
everyone has access to and Google will
make that access even more prevalent so
it is speed to market and the cost at
which you got to market which will
determine because it doesn't matter I
mean the it's getting faster and faster
where people are able to replicate your
IP so hopefully there will be a change
or shift in mindset which will focus
more on speed and quality and the cost
at which you get this done rather than
protecting something that is not even
worth protecting because it will become
obsolete in in four months or five
months that speed of of silences is
growing so hopefully that's where things
go the most interesting thing we've done
is we predicted the quality of wine okay
that was our first competition that's
how I got the community going so my
thought was you know let it be something
interesting which they've not done
before so we got a lot of
physicochemical properties of grapes and
and where grapes are grown and this was
for a specific wine in Spain and we
basically created an algorithm that
replaces the wine connoisseur okay and
and gives a score to all wines so yeah
that was injects the score predicts the
score so that was interesting yeah yeah
there you want to make sure of specific
know that they have care they healthcare
work that will go in there and work
around sepsis detection it's really kind
of I would spend most fun for us yeah
okay yeah obviously conserve what are
the barriers to adoption of offender of
big data big data itself there's no
privacy
if you're doing it in your adoption of
our service yes
privacy is is a concern but beyond that
the value of getting a lot of different
eyes on a problem that is not fully
defined in in a period of time which is
almost 1/10 of what would be possible
in-house at a cost that is I don't want
to get into cost and in this
conversation I don't know whether it's
fair or right but it's it's a really low
cost compared to what you would do on
your own
so none of those are barriers so the way
we are addressing it right now is there
is enough value to be given to you using
publicly available information let me
give that to you first right yeah back
in the old marketing space I remember
how much money it was worth to a direct
mailing company to increase their
response rate from 1.5% exactly so
that's one that's all there was is a
multi-million dollar question for them
and we were able to increase it by 400%
for one of the companies ok from 1% to
four thousand five what do you think I
wish the answer the question was
people's understanding of the value to
get from Big Data I think like like you
know we mentioned earlier most folks
have made investments in Hadoop systems
but they are quite sure what to do with
it so they've kind of got the Ferrari
sitting in the garage and the keys are
in and everyone's walking around looking
at it and touching it but no one's
actually taking it out for a test drive
yet so it's you know practically it's
probably been you know folks that
haven't had the budget to spend and the
folks that have have sort of spent the
money on it now they have the
infrastructure I think you know we're
we're forget it's Oracle maybe just to
the serve am I'm forgetting who did it
but 85 to 90 percent of big data
installations right now are all in the
trial phase right not moved into
production so you know I think for the
folks that haven't invested people are
now starting to sit on the sidelines and
wait to see you know what is the outcome
of all the investment that's gone into
big data so far before they you know
before they take the plunge which is why
we let them do it online as a service
because it's not easy
and and it does not it just adds to your
IT infrastructure it does not replace
anything so your previous Oracle your
business object they all remain this is
just one other thing you need to deal
with so the early groups in this were
the risk management people in the
financial institutions one of the things
that we've seen in terms of industry
cycles is that the companies that we're
doing social media analytics have been
bought by the big firms like Oracle or
like salesforce.com and so when you see
the big companies buying up rapidly
emerging companies you definitely see
that it's going mainstream I mean that's
really within a couple of years of being
something that they see as critical to
themselves yeah it shows you where
enterprises are spending money around
big data yeah so so yes the social media
analytics companies were able to go into
larger companies and give a compelling
story as to how the social media
analytics can help your business and
enough of them were able to sell that
story and all of a sudden an Oracle and
a Google noticed and they bought a
wildfire yeah they bought a buddy media
and brought them in-house because it
okay the social media story for big data
is in place it'll be interesting to see
is as there's other trends in
acquisitions you can see which areas of
Big Data are starting to resonate and
have business impact because they will
get bought by these larger players yeah
that's all another hand somewhere go
ahead fine how much repeat business I
see from customers because being able to
generate insights is one thing using it
inside to get ROI in the company is
another thing
so is it like once company goes to one
nitrogen they're like okay this is
working it gets fat with the high of
investment or is it like the biggest
step back to revive it what just
happened yeah a little bit of both so
part of what we do is like I mentioned
before start with the very specific use
case and then we grow that over time so
part of you know our strategy and go to
market is to find companies that are big
enough that we can grow with over time
that our platform
groweth and then we look for industries
where there's repeatability between
different customers so we look for
problems where we can solve it for one
customer we know that that problem also
exists for other customers in the space
that we can go resell that same solution
too yeah so just to kind of bring it
back to Asia
do you see Asia as a major area for the
expansion its just speaking personally
yes
yeah we've got a number of pilots that
are starting for us the you know in our
experience the early adopter here has
been Japan although I mentioned we've
were in conversations now with some
folks in Korea and China as well but
Japan there are a number of larger
conglomerates that exist there that are
looking at this cloud growth especially
the adoption of consumer cloud and
seeing that as a primary driver for
their growth especially folks that have
traditionally been more hardware or
enterprise software products so that
growth growth curve that I showed before
is driving interest from Japanese
companies how to build out their own
clouds and capture that business if you
have just for you know be clear I
include India and Asia okay what do you
say about in terms of expansion from
this point in Asia you're saying yeah I
mean there's this I'm seeing as much
demand or desire in in all our
conversations in India as I said once
they become more mature in in terms of
handling their datasets and yes cloud is
is one possibility
they're not as paranoid by the way as
you find in the u.s. because the laws
here are I mean the lawyer always comes
into the picture no matter what but in
India you know as long as there's value
people will be more open and I feel that
similar in in Asian countries as well we
are trying to partner with the company
to get into Singapore and Hong Kong but
it's it's similar I don't think you know
once the data maturity happens you will
see a huge growth in in Asian countries
disappeared his results in your thoughts
so apart from money the incentive really
is peer validation it's it's it's a very
different kind of peep you know a bunch
of people right it's they're they're
driven by challenges they're driven by
more interesting problems and he knows
that and the as long as you keep them
challenged and and so we run a lot of
self sponsored competitions as well okay
we don't just rely on these mundane
problems as far as the contestant is
concerned of just you know doing some
sort of churn analytics that's that's
very common for them so we always keep
them you know occupied with more and new
interesting challenges that in turn
helps us develop these models which
becomes part of our repository and which
which could eventually become in to turn
into solutions at a later stage of
course the fact that they are mentioned
openly publicly on a leaderboard that
helps a lot okay you it gives you
visibility right I'm and you're being
compared on something that you are good
at and you're being compared with people
across the globe so what about open
source how does this fit in with the
whole kind of you know open source
movement in software of both of you
Divya is our is the analytics being
developed the individual developers keep
their IP how does that work yes that's a
good question so as opposed to the open
source world in software so like Linux
or something where people just came
together on their own in in many ways
and and kept improving each other's code
we are just orchestrating that same
phenomenon right now what happens is
that when an algorithm gets gets
developed on our platform in return for
the prize money so if there is no prize
money paid that algorithm continues to
belong to
whoever whoever now that algorithm does
get transferred to us in return for
prize money however because we are not
selling the model as I mentioned to you
we are selling the outcome of the the
model or the algorithm any gains that we
get from that also gets shared in the
form of some sort of royalty with you
know with these always so that's another
gain that they get alright so if you're
good at this it's possible that if we
grow you grow along with us open-source
is already a really a key component of
the data science community so you look
at the work done with our most of that
work is open Apache mahout there is a
lot of great algorithm libraries
available today and I think you made the
comment earlier it's not the algorithms
a lot of times it's the actual
implementation of them so understanding
how to get the data into an environment
where it'll actually work with an
algorithm and that's what a lot of what
we do and then in addition to that you
need the algorithm but you also need all
the infrastructure to ingest and store
the data that a lot of times is not
trivial work it's it's work that can be
done but it tends to look similar from
company to company and so packaging up
is a cloud platform abstracts away a lot
of the unnecessary repeating of that
work to set up the infrastructure so I
think that we're about out of time and
what I'd like to do to end this up is
just say stay tuned everybody this is a
really amazing emerging industry it is
growing at an amazing rate already I
think as people use more and more data
from mobile devices as people do more
and more real kind real-time analysis of
what's going on you're going to see more
and more kinds of data feeding into
these models more and more correlation
it's really exciting and I'm very
excited that we could get both of you to
be here at the same time
thanks very much show me yeah thank you
you